-Our first guest to night is
an Emmy-nominated comedian
You know her from her work on
"Saturday Night Live,"
"Coming to America,"
and "Our Flag Means Death."
She's hosting "The Daily Show"
January 17th through the 19th
on Comedy Central,
and her podcast,
"The Fckry with Leslie Jones
& Lenny Marcus"
airs new episodes on Thursdays,
Please welcome back
to the show our good friend,
Leslie Jones, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Leslie, as I live and breathe!
-So...
Yes, let me sit
so I don't show my cooch.
-Okay, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
You're very, very polite.
-Yes.
-You've gone to a manners and
etiquette class, I can tell.
How are you?
-I learned how to say "Cooch."
[ Laughter ]
-It's so nice to have you back.
-Well, thank you.
It's always good
to be here with you.
-This is a very exciting week
for you being in New York City.
I want to ask about
"The Daily Show,"
but I also --
Fred isn't here this week,
-Fred, my husband.
-Yeah, because you were on
"Our Flag Means Death,"
And you were Spanish Jackie, and
Fred was one of your husbands.
-Yes. He was one of
my favorite husbands, too.
-That's so lovely.
-Because he would help me
get dressed, you know?
-We would talk about
business things, you know?
Sometimes he got a little touchy
in public, but it was cool.
-That's cool. It's good
to have multiple husbands
in case one of them runs afowl.
-It's good to have
multiple husbands.
-Now, you got to shoot
the show in New Zealand.
-Yes.
-How did you enjoy New Zealand?
-I enjoyed it for the first
week I was there
'cause, you know,
you're a tourist.
You're like, I'm in New Zealand!
-Yeah.
-You insult a couple of new
Zealanders by saying,
"Oh, this is just like
Australia."
And then they go --
-Yeah.
-And then everything is off
the land.
They're really fresh out there,
but they don't have, like,
the same type of food.
It's just, like, a lot of lamb.
-uh-huh.
-A lot of heavy pies.
You didn't care for the menu?
-Not after a week.
After a week, I was like,
I don't want another pie.
-uh-huh.
-I don't want another pie.
-You hit your pie limit?
-I hit my pie --
and I never thought
I would say those words.
-Uh-huh.
-Pie limit.
-Yeah.
Were you near the water?
-Yes.
-Were you, like, on the coast?
You must have been for
"Our Flag Means Death."
-And the weather was crazy
'cause
you know how they sell it.
It was like, oh, we're doing it
in New Zealand,
and it's going to be
during the summertime?
-Right.
-It's going to be hot out there.
They said it was gonna be
beautiful, they said.
And we got out there, and it
rained every day.
And not just regular rain,
like,
that rain where I called
the front desk and was like, yo,
Are we safe?
Like seriously, how many floors
up do I need to be
to not get hit by the tsunami?
[ Laughter ]
-And this is really cool.
I'm very impressed that you
spent your time there.
You also did some stand-up in
New Zealand.
-Yes!
-How did you find the crowds?
-Oh, my goodness, so calm.
[ Laughter ]
They were so reserved and
kicked-back,
but I guess you can be reserved
and kick-back in New Zealand.
You don't got to be crazy
Americans.
They're like drinking wine and
tea and, you know --
-They got big bellies
full of lamb pie.
-You know what I'm saying?
[ Inaudible ] crazy American.
-Because you're very
calm on stage?
-No, at all.
So, it was a lot of --
it was a lot of, "Whoa."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you have a New
Zealand accent now?
-Oh, that's so cruel
for you to do that.
The only thing I know how to do
is say "no" in New Zealand.
-Okay.
-Naw-o.
[ Laughter ]
-So it's four syllables.
-Yes.
Nah-o.
-So you've had a podcast
with your friend Lenny.
I have been lucky enough
to do it.
It's a blast. Tell me how --
You guys obviously have
a great chemistry.
How long have you known Lenny,
and how did you meet him?
-Well, you know at The Cellar,
you know, when you sit
at Estee's table,
you meet, like, a little,
you know --
-Comedy cellar here in
New York.
-Yeah, a caravan of comedians
that's always sitting
at the table, and Lenny
was there one year
I think when I first got "SNL."
He was there, and he was talking
about this girl he was dating.
And I was like, "Oh, wow, this
girl, you should definitely,
you know, be with this girl.
Then the next year I came in
because you know "SNL"
keeps you busy.
-Yeah.
-I saw him the next --
the following year,
and he's like
getting married to her.
And I was like, yeah, you know,
get -- marry the girl, whatever.
Then I think the third year,
between that and --
they were sitting there
watching the Yankees,
and they was watching
it on TV, cheering.
I was like, I can get seats to
the Yankees.
So I took them to
Lauren's seats.
-Wow, those are good seats.
Those are the good seats.
-Oh, man, we had --
We lau-- I just, like, laughed.
We were just laughing, like just
easy laugh and kicking it.
He had already gave me some
notes like, you know,
when we came off the stage
he had, like, this little,
you know nerds.
-Yeah.
-He had the whole -- you know,
he had the whole like --
-Yeah, they write small.
-Really small!
Nerds like that
tiny handwriting.
-Really small.
Really small.
Like my whole set was on this
little bitty piece of paper.
Then he had equations by it.
-It's no fair because
they have glasses.
So their glasses can see
tiny writing, yeah.
-Especially his.
His is especially nerdy.
You know what I'm saying?
So he has like a nerd --
But he gave me like some notes,
and I used 8 out of 10
of the jokes.
And I was like, "Oh, dude."
So we were sitting at the game,
and I was like, yo, dude,
you want to come
and open for me?
And he came and opened up for
me, and that was it.
-That's great.
And now you have a budding
friendship, which is --
-Yes.
-Which is fantastic.
-And we write so well
together.
-That's really great.
It's lucky to have
someone like that.
-When he was there, we
were talking about --
you're very kind, talking about
how I'm the greatest living
American impressionist.
-Which you are, though.
-Thank you very much.
I don't brag about it.
That's not my style.
-The Obama one
is my favorite one.
I'm sorry.
-But you --
You were talking about --
you know I do an Al Pacino,
but you have an Al Pacino story
that I would very much
like you to share
when you saw it.
-He's gonna take me tell it.
-It's just too good.
-Okay. So -- okay.
So first of all, y'all need to
know I'm ignorant, okay?
I have no chill whatsoever.
So we're standing in front of
this hotel,
And I -- you know, I
spot Al Pacino.
And I go over, and I'm like,
"Oh, my God. I love you."
I think you're one of the best
actors in this business.
You know, I'm bowing to him, and
I was like,
the work that you did in
"The Godfather" and woo, woo.
You're just so woo, woo, woop,
woop, and I'm going off.
And then he looks up at me.
He goes --
he just looks, and then he
walks off and gets into the car.
And then my friend comes over,
and he goes,
you know that was
Dustin Hoffman, right?
[ Laughter ]
And Dustin Hoffman, he was
like --
Dustin Hoffman was probably
like, damn,
Latifa be trippin'.
[ Laughter ]
-I got a lot more to ask
you about.
This week's host of
"The Daily Show."
We'll be right back
with Leslie Jones.